hello audience i just wanted to talk to
you about one of the greatest james
games of his generation one of the most
intelligently written influential and
most artistically viable
in the entire universe i mean this is
talking we're talking great gatsby level
of art
truly nothing in the past 20 years has
ever been this intelligently written
truly truly this is the citizen kane of
video games
so rich with subtlety
oh reversing my controls
you choose that our reality can be
reversed
or that perhaps our perspective may not
always be the right one perhaps we are
looking at things the wrong way and need
to invert our views
the fact that the villain is a russian
is speaking to the real problem that
russians are stereotyped as friendly and
loving
russians are almost like the canada of
countries
ah obscuring my target behind a piece of
wood that is what soldiers know these
days killing
they must take the lives of enemies they
can't even see
much like
the bombing of hiroshima this snack
machine is an allegory for the fragile
nature of the food industry in america
and how in an instant it can be
destroyed
clearly call of duty is pro-abortion
it's not subtle about that
you're choking on the subtlety
which is how it's sad it represents the
repetitive cycle of war
and chaos and destruction
this is such a
so deep of a storm
the
entire
deep
invigorating to say the least
i'm aroused by how deep it is
you are smashing a melon a melon is a
symbol of the feminine and the natural
and you are destroying that
and you are evil i interpret the
destruction of a melon as military
overgrowth in the destruction of nature
as a result of it
or perhaps it is both symbolizing that
mother nature is a battered woman
the fact that i cannot execute him in
cold blood is speaking to the
powerlessness of the common foot soldier
and that there is a price to be paid for
everything in this world your entire
life in the military your viability is a
member of this new society
a regime in which all members of society
must be
very well must be vetted and if they are
then it shall be destroyed
they shall be killed like these
cardboard cutouts of undesirables
oh no i seem to have wandered into a
broom closet and the rest of society
with you
i can only describe myself with the
adjective
pardon
at the sight of such brilliance
you are the soup and the waters outside
this boat represents stalinism
friendly fire is not tolerated because
you are not allowed to have friends
this staircase is actually a callback to
that staircase from earlier
this toilet represents the economy
for nefarious purposes and this is very
nature and this iron
and the fact that the boat is tilting is
signifying that the storm of soap and
water that you are rinsing away the
filth of the world with
or that america is in a precarious
situation teetering on the edge of
destruction and order republicans the
only ones who can save this country with
their evil ways
from their evil ways
from their own evil ways
exactly
storytelling
we cannot understand it is too subtle
i seem to have dropped a grenade again
because the controls are different from
the ps3 version of what to do